brauchen wir wieder hin ganz cool aber
jetzt ganz schnell ich zu meiner frage
käme und der hatte hatten sich
gestritten wird wie stehst du zu stärken
oder wie stets zu zweit weil du warst
auch über den handel bürger hängen oder
bist du ja auch immer noch würde mich
echt interessieren oder wenn es um
privates naja ist eine private sache da
hat er recht aber der krasse frage ich
bin so dieser unparteiische typ
sowie bei der religion auch so ich suche
ein team also das beste raus und so aber
mit ich verstehe mich mit alberto ich
verstehe mich mit cheng deswegen dessen
probleme geben mich nichts an und ich
meine dann auch kollege von mir in einer
beziehung mit einer frau und problem hat
da geh ich doch nicht dazwischen und
sagt zu halten so ja kommen geht mir
einfach nichts anlass ist dessen sache
aber die sache hat sie auch schon ganz
lange geklärt wie die user denken dann
auch immer da ist irgendwas zu holen die
sache hat sich erledigt und alles ist
gut hat sich keiner geprügelt geflossen
alles in ordnung